تقاوم ولكن
لا تخفي اوكرانيا صعوبه الموقف في ضخمه
فما زال القتال ضاريا بالقرب من المدينه
الاستراتيجيه الشرقيه البلاد وما زالت
الانباء تصل منه هناك متضاربه هل توقت
القوات الروسيه ضخمه فعل يؤكد مسؤولون في
اداره اقليم دانيات المواليه لموسكو حدوث
الامر اما من يديرون المعارك حقا عن
الجانب الروسي فيتريثون تقول ميليشيا
فاجنر انها ستعلن ذاك المكسب الميداني اذا
تحقق في حينه
لحظه ضخمه باهميه استراتيجيه تقع على ضفه
نهر ضخم توفى شماليه مقاطعه دونياسك في
اقليم الدومباز وتبعد نحو 600 كيلو متر عن
العاصمه كيف
وتعاد المدينه بالنسبه للاوكرانيين حصنا
للدفاع عن باقي مدن
ومنطلقا لضربتها الى المواقع الروسيه اما
الروس فبعد خسارتهم مدينه ايزيوم جنوب
خاركيف اصبحت البوابه الجنوبيه الشرقيه
شبه الوحيده لتقدم قوتهم فيضان
تبحث روسي عن انتصار كبير على محور مخبوت
ما دفعها بحسب ما نقلته صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه الى تغيير تكتيكاتها
العسكريه اذ انتقلت من القصف الصاروخي الى
الدفع بموجات بشريه كبيره من المقاتلين
لاقتحام خطوط الدفاع الاوكرانيه اما في
خرسون جنوبا فتكثف القوات الروسيه ضربتها
بالتزامنه مع نقل تعزيزات من شبه جزيره
القرم الى جنوب المقاطعه هل تتهاب موسكو
لامر ما يتجدد السؤال ومعه تنطلق التكهنات
حوله هجوم في الربيع او ربما قبله طالما
نبهه تركيا الى ان الروسي يعد دون له
يقول امين مجلس الامن القومي الاوكراني ان
روسيا تستعد لشن هجوم كبير جديد على
اوكرانيا خلال اسبوعين او ثلاثه
ان هناك احتمالا كبيرا لشن بوتين هجوما
جديدا من الشمال والجنوب والشرق كما حدث
في بدايه الحرب كما يشير الى ان المعارك
الاصعب لم تاتي بعد وانا شهور القليله
المقبله ستكون حاسمه في تحديد مسار الحرب
الى ساحته
لاي محاوله اوكرانيه
يقول ان مهمه وزاره الدفاع هي منع ذلك
الاحتمال لكن بوتين لا يوضح ما اذا كان
النطاق الجغرافي الذي يقصده
من اراضي اوكرانيه اما انه يقف عند حدود
التي يعترف بها العالم